get her to act cute and big
okay
play his guitar with his feet
[Music]
i just hit my credit limit alright
thanks for you next time
[Music]
what's up my fellow geeks i'm zachy and
we're back for another round of antics
shenanigans and a whole lot of fun today
joining me is
[Music]
hello
hi nikki hi now this is not your first
time here no it's not so previously i
was the victim of all the little things
that geek culture has gotten me to do
but hey
like now i'm here
so debbie was one of the lucky winners
to beat our challenges on twitch and one
self a few wonderful rewards courtesy of
logitech and we're here to do the same
thing again okay
we've got the logitech stream cam the
blue yeti x mx master 3s is some new
gear right here annoying and of course
let's see here uh the mx keys mini as
well let's
i don't think you can bite that but yeah
okay so let me
let's do it yeah let's go
okay debbie you know how this goes we
find streamers who need an upgrade and
bless them at a price wait wait wait
hold up
again like with a prize can we just give
it to them
what are you doing in this video i mean
i have a good heart okay i have a good
heart why would this we can't make it
too easy we gotta get them to do
something okay hello hello
guppy fish which hello geek culture
guppy
would you like the particular challenge
what is this challenge dance to
jake
spooky
6 19.
very nice number dance to jiggle jiggle
what again return for dancing
why are you singing it guppy you're
supposed to be dancing through it can
you remember any of the rap that you did
my money don't jiggle
[Laughter]
oh wow
[Applause]
how do we up the ante now for sixty nine
dollars he has to do the exact same
thing shirtless we want you to jiggle
jiggle topless
for sixty dollars
let's wait for him to do it first before
we give him the 69. oh okay then we
don't write
for sure
[Applause]
[Laughter]
so about that 69
i just hit my credit limit
alright thanks for your next time
[Music]
looks like we have this streamer charlie
xx playing valerian you play a lot of
valerian don't you yeah i do
have to see let's check the stream
quality real quick
720p 60s
really
darling you must hold the w key for the
entire round and you're not allowed to
walk
no shift i'll unbind it okay i'll unbind
it no shift wow
wow
no walk one round or the whole full
round until you win until i win
i cannot stop only w key
excuse me
i put my back as air so i was like why
am i stuck
god
bro so how's the day everybody
if you chance la for three rounds
continuously say positive things to your
teammates do not start
my introvertedness is like
you know
no
now get her to act cute
because i i don't have it in me i've
never done it before in my entire life
you won the stream came or not i won
okay trust me i got this
okay
bye thanks for the game
[Music]
thank you yes [ __ ] we got it we are
going into some history here with cheryl
peppero hello boyfriend
wow someone's singing
for me looking for a boyfriend
looking
[Music]
it's okay
saying your lowest note and highest note
for the next song i can do that how
about how about we get everyone to to
participate in this challenge i'm gonna
start medium
and okay y'all can type in chat if you
want it to go high or low and i will
okay we've been together
i need the other one to help you make
you feel
[Music]
let's just go higher
[Music]
after all this time
[Music]
thank you for the 10 q stops oh my gosh
i mean you see there's a little bit of
flicker right here
1080p okay why not 60 fps so she isn't
due for upgrade maybe a new mic as well
well
how about a new microphone
oh my gosh
say no more
what what do you want me to do we're
gonna challenge cheryl
to write a four-liner song to thank our
sponsors of course logitech and she has
to sing and dance
let's write a song let's write a song
okay i like this let's go a few moments
later
[Music]
makes me wanna sing
is it time for logitech here everybody
say thank you to geek culture just in
case you missed out this video is
brought to you by logitech tons of
amazing gear i use them myself use them
too and what i really love is this
logitech stream cam great for gamers and
streamers and it's 1080p 60fps and over
here i have the blue yeti x and if you
ever want to sound delicious and extra
thick like a radio presenter or if you
want to give yourself different voice
effects this microphone is
check this out
[Music]
so plenty of effects and presets to
choose from if you guys would like to
know more about these products do check
out the description below
all right we've got jam bread music
culture what's up what keyboard is he
using a cheap 12 keyboard recorder yeah
i mean look he has nice pc setup here
you got the guitars even got a projector
at the back everything looks good except
for that keyboard all right gembrett how
about a challenge
challenge i hope it's a music challenge
shall we get jen brett to play his
guitar with his feet
[Music]
okay
play the guitar with a gorgeous fit
[Music]
second
done this in my whole life before
[Music]
okay my hands are here okay i'm not
kidding
[Music]
harder
[Music]
[Music]
round two a keyboard yeti mic stream cam
and a mouse
g culture
do you come to my stream just because
you saw my 12 dollars keyboard i want to
i want you to shred
as hard as you can
smash that 20 keyboard
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
it live it
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
geek culture asked me to do this and
never give me keyboard well i didn't
know keyboard already is here
let me try to plug this back
it still connects let's see the moment
of truth
oh my god
yo
it's broken into too late bro what the
hey geek culture thank you so so much
all right zeki so who are we going to go
to next this is
playing with her hair okay how about
this oh she's straight oh she's curling
okay how about this what about this
challenge for 6.90 we get her to do
something really crazy for her why don't
she just like give herself the you know
the kung fu hustle auntie look kung fu
has
i can try a few curls
i look like i have pretzels on my head
[Laughter]
like so princess leia buns but oh my god
the oven was not hot enough
you want me to draw a mole okay i'm
gonna keep six for the mole and i'll
triple it for a unibrow
[Laughter]
oh i think it's not bad
and i think i still look pretty good i
think it's doing pretty good
[Laughter]
you ready to earn
dream cam hold okay what do i need to do
give us a guinness world record of
cartwheels in your room so i'm sorry
one
two
three
five
if you think about it right after doing
this that completes the whole look
already yeah she's going
again
wow
where did the energy come from what's
going on
[Music]
alrighty i think our streamers have
already received their logitech packages
let's check out their new setup
are you ready
let's try that again
[Music]
start with
the mouse mx master 3s i have never
owned a mouse that is not
basic
wow this is bigger than i expected it's
like the size of my face
i've always wanted a logitech like mini
keyboard that's pink
honestly
wow the color is so nice
it looks nice right
it's a logitech mx keys mini the mini
looks so tiny
actually but you can actually bring
these around in and do outside which is
what i like about it
g435
logitech wireless gaming headset the
color is so nice right i think this is a
super huge upgrade because i've been
using this very broken earpiece
as you can tell it's a nice color for
you there's a very subtle color right
and i love them i love them like i can
literally stand up and and jam and the
sound the sound quality is pretty good
as well the stream cam
is logitech for creators
i am a creator now it looks like that
is
the logitech stream cam it's very
flexible in a sense that you can turn
the cam up and down very easily compared
to my previous one hi cheryl
hi
how are you doing today
tada this is the blue yeti x mic this is
me on the blue yeti
can you all hear it hello testing this
is cardioid which is one side only i
think we also have the omni everywhere
it's like the
on around you
i think this is the asmr one
let me do some tapping
geek culture thank you so much for all
the equipment really really appreciate
it okay so this is the first thing that
they gave me the logitech stream cam
i love the autofocus you do you like it
do you like the the clearness of me you
can you can see me properly now you're
looking very
yeah you're looking very foggers
i'm unboxing a blue yeti wow hello hello
hello
hello hello but it's something that i'm
very excited for i needed a mouse like
really bad okay my mouse is actually
wired so i'm happy now that i have a
new mouse that i can use
um
so i can
but yeah i'll definitely be changing the
wireless i think it's a lot better thank
you geek culture again for all the
swaggies
thanks
for watching cheese they sent over this
g915 tkl the wireless keyboard
oh my goodness
look at this it's a shorter keyboard
than what i have apparently it's pretty
light my parents are gonna thank me for
like having such a quieter keyboard it's
so pretty it's like rgb it feels really
nice on my fingers when i type logitech
stream cam is the before
this
is the after
dude
i'm so much brighter tell me
am i clear more show more sharp right
it's more sharp right blue yeti might
blue
it's
it's really amazing i'm in love
there is different effects that i can
use
the what hit set
g733
look it's
it lights up it's
chef pizza this is my first unboxing
stream guys mx mechanical is i think
it's new right it looks so slick
so pretty huh
i think the colors are so nice
this is my first keyboard guys okay
maybe the second one the first one is
this one let's compare it huh
one is uh
one is dangly one is not
perfectly matched the size here
it's
kind of like windows and mac compatible
just because you guys just want to
listen to me type right
if you ask me to rate the keyboard
firstly 10 over 10 hello because
mainly well this one is about i would
say three over ten
wow
it's a new microphone
so nice man you love it it's like so
neat and clean the color as well what is
up everybody
yeah what is up
hello
what's up
hello what's up
oh my god it's so loud
the moment of truth
oh my god
there is this no i'm not blocking this
yo
nice dual camera set up what do you guys
think it's so nice guys look at that
so this is how you clamp it
you can flip it and i think that you can
also flip it this way
look at that
portrait bro what the this is so cool
it's this thing called auto framing
[Music]
i really think this is the
the best webcam i've ever seen doesn't
look like a webcam at all
let me compare to my macbook's webcam
you know that is rubbish right
i look extra
handsome what do you guys think
talking about camera angles for guitar
this final song let's do that huh
thank you all so much
very nice safe to say we did a good job
didn't we oh yeah we did it's always
nice to see streamers streams elevated
and all thanks to logitech we can now
give back to our twitch community yes so
we hope you enjoyed this video and stay
tuned for more content just like this
here on geek culture debbie thank you so
much for joining us thank you for having
me and to those watching do not forget
to like and subscribe we'll see you on
the next one bye
[Music]
you